- I heard that actually-
Was it you two?
You play guitar and y'all kept
everybody entertained, right?
During the shoot?
- There was some music to be had
but mostly it was Jeff at the
piano and people joining him
'cause he can play anything,
and it was a lot of fun, a lot of fun.
- I like to play. He's a musical genius.
(Chris scoffs)
There was a whole evening,
a one man show.
If you give him a guitar...
- [Kelly] I had no idea.
- Oh yeah. He's great.
- I didn't know you played.
- He sings. Just all kinds.
- And you sing?
(Chris stammering)
How did I miss this?
- When Kelly Clarkson
asks you if you sing,
you better be able to sing.
(audience laughs)
And I can't sing.
- I'm just saying, it
could be a trio moment now,
'cause I didn't know he could do that too.
- He sings great.
(audience cheers)
- I'm in.
- He doesn't like to be fenced in either.
- And DeWanda is a wonderful
singer. DeWanda sang with us.
- Again, I echo what Chris just said,
when Kelly Clarkson asks
if you can sing...
- Everyone is backing out.
Everyone is like, "I'm not
going karaoke-ing with you."
It's not happening.
- I will. I'll karaoke.
- I love karaoke.
Well, obviously, a whole
show I started with it.
But I love it, 'cause
it's funny to do songs
people don't expect, so I usually rap.
What do you do at karaoke?
- Oh man, it kind of depends
on what I've been drinking
and how much I've been drinking, you know?
- Yes. There is a difference
between beer and liquor.
- Yeah. I'm Whitney Houston
when I'm really drunk.
- [Jeff] Wow.
(Kelly laughing)
- But I'm "Pour Some Sugar On Me"
- I think we all are.
- when I'm just buzzed.
- Yes. Okay, okay.
What's your go-to for karaoke?
- I don't drink.
- Well, you don't have to drink.
(guests laughing)
- That's a good answer.
- She's like, I don't drink,
therefore I don't do karaoke.
- Therefore, those two can't
exist without the other.
- Correct, correct.
- That's amazing.
- The last time I did
karaoke was with Amy Adams
and I retired after that.
Have you ever done karaoke with her?
- No, but I've sung
with her in "Enchanted."
We sound great together at
home, when I'm singing with her.
- She's serious about
karaoke. Very serious.
- She's got a great voice.
- Yes. So I said I'm not
gonna take up anymore space
in the karaoke world.
- But people aren't supposed
to be real at karaoke.
You're supposed to be funny.
You're supposed to do some kind of funny-
if you really are a singer-
- She managed to do all of
those things simultaneously.
- Okay. Okay. Well, go ahead, Amy Adams,
be fabulous at everything.
Do y'all like karaoke?
Well, you do it, you
probably sing everything.
DeWanda, what's your go to?
- See, that's the thing. Bryce
and I are secretly twins.
So I also do not drink,
therefore I do not do karaoke.
(DeWanda laughing)
- We always learn about new
things every five minutes or so.
- Every five minutes at least. Yeah.
- We've never discussed
this prior to this moment.
- This is news, but not news.
- Yes.
- Okay, what about you
Mamoudou? What do you do?
- "Twist and Shout," I also
don't drink, by the way.
"Twist and Shout."
- [Kelly] You don't drink either?
- Nah. It's no good for me.
- You don't have to drink,
it's an interesting thing.
- Yeah, (indistinct)
some "Twist and Shout"
and "Sympathy for the Devil."
- [Kelly and DeWanda]
"Sympathy for the Devil."
♪ Please excuse me while I ♪
(Jeff sings gibberish)
♪ I'm a man of wealth and taste ♪
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh my God.